because i'm a lead pipe wielding
professional i go through the uh
uh information uh background of our
guest and i knew he played for mariucci
because he was the subject of one of the
greatest mariachi stories that's ever
been told
but very rarely in public um and he
he was also i do believe in the rose
bowl building when i was there covering
the university of michigan's loss to his
usc trojans
whoa and beau schembeckler's final game
he now portrays andre the giant in young
rock that airs tonight every tuesday
on nbc at 8 pm eastern time also
available on peacock the next day
we're available on peacock every day
from 12 to 3 eastern
matthew willig here on the rich eisen
show how are you bud i was just trying
to order a pizza
and got put on hold i don't know what's
going on
can i get you what can i get you matthew
what can i get you
extra meat and well done that's all i
want extra meat
and well done crispy excellent by the
way
how's that for a bullish order that
sounds rich it's great to be back on
your show great to have you back here
studio thank you
no it's all good brother it's all good
to have you here and uh there's so much
to
to hit you on about this show and we'll
we'll hit on that in a second is that
accurate were you on the usc team that
beat
beauchem beckler in his final game yeah
yeah i think we talked about that last
time i was in but uh yeah it was kind of
i think it was blows last year
if i believe that last game matthew last
game
and bo uh beau uncorked a fake punt with
three minutes to go
and it was called back due to holding uh
a penalty that i still don't know
uh actually existed to be quite frankly
you know what i i have
i have personal experience with those
types of things getting flags for no
reason
i can appreciate it yes but but
on this on this at this instance i was
the benefactor so
uh screwball like i can't even say
that no i know i guess you can say that
about that that's a tough one
his last game that was that was brutal
but you know that was the third rose
bowl game that i had been to at sc
and the first one we'd won so it was
kind of i was due
but also i i think we discussed this the
last time you were here but this being a
whole new audience and we're here on
peacock where
your show can be seen every single day
after it airs on nbc and young rock
um that uh i i remember uh
sitting up there in the rose bowl press
box watching the game
and thinking there were two number 55s
on defense that day and it was really
only one and it was junior sail playing
out of his mind or
or like he always played what was he
like as a teammate
matthew he was great you know he was my
roommate
uh freshman year so we roomed together
and so he
being about as raw as you can be as an
individual
uh being a prop 48 guy so he didn't play
the first season
first year uh just going to school
he was maniacal in about everything he
did if you can imagine
um still had that islander in him a
little bit
i remember stealing a lava lava from him
little you know those little skirt
things that he uh wore
but um even back then he was a little
bit of uh
he was a little manic you know to be
honest with you
a little bit up and down all the time
but but again
a what a tear on the field
the guy just wanted to play he just
wanted to go and he you know he's one of
those just
true football guys um
and it was kind of obviously very sad uh
ending to it uh you know and i kind of
felt i felt that we had played each
other uh
in the pros you know years later and
and i went to hit him on a play and he
looked at me like he didn't even know
who i was
so there was that i saw that a little
earlier on you know that there was a
little bit of disconnect from something
that was going on there which
again was sad but i mean i guess it made
him who he was in a first ballot hall of
famer posthumously and
and um i i'll never forget that day
i'm like this is the the greatest
defensive performance i've ever seen
he was everywhere on
he was running around just like you said
he was running around
he seemed to be everywhere on the field
i remember that distinctly just like you
do
and again thankfully i was on the good
side of that
and and you played with and for pretty
much
everybody that i've worked with on nfl
game day morning in nfl network pretty
much
with the exception of it with the
exception maybe sap and and
and irv you won a super bowl in 99
with my buddies falcon warner what was
it like to be on that team
matthew it was it was uh you could sense
the greatness
as you were amongst it it really was
amazing um
you know i came in sort of late to that
season like i
like just the very beginning of the
season and they had already kind of
gotten things going that i was
brought in basically as a backup uh you
know if they needed me that was a better
at that point but um just to watch those
guys do what they did and you know
something isn't being rich was and you
can imagine this
excuse me that just practice just
watching them
practice right was impressive because
you know let's face it we we had a
pretty good defense as well
you know it was a pretty solid group of
guys but to watch
these guys in practice do what they did
was
just it made it almost sort of normal
you know by the time we get to sundays
it was like yo of course
we're putting up these points and of
course we're doing these things well it
was it was pretty
amazing what was your view of the final
play where where were you
um in relation to i was pretty close to
uh to coach vermeel um
and uh you know there was a little bit
of like it was kind of blocked a little
bit you know because of the players on
the field
and so there was a feeling of what
happened did he get you know
one of those things and i remember just
i think you see in the video
of the game everybody was sort of
inching towards the field going
we know it's over but are we excited or
are we not and then we finally realized
that it was he was stopped and
uh it was pretty great what a great
feeling one
yard shy matthew willow gear on the rich
eisen show
your give me your best mooch store give
me your best one and then we'll
we'll we'll turn to your acting career
oh god come on give me a great boot
story
come on now i was telling somebody this
morning i was like i need a good story
for rich
and uh i'm not sure i have another good
story from you know listen mitch
lucha was great i i spent the time um
way back when that that he was
my favorite coach he really was he was a
guy that uh
as a veteran he came in and he loved the
o-line
he loved ro line specifically uh and he
had sort of that craziness to him so he
loved the stuff that we did you know the
the pranks and things like that you know
as long as we were doing our stuff on
the field but
i just love moods there's not much to
say about him other than like i said
i think he was just the perfect coach he
has that
had that ability to be able to
communicate with every guy on the roster
up and down and um
but i just love the fact he's that
italian sort of you know moving with his
hands and everything has got to be
over the top and you know we love that
his storytelling is second to none
matthew and
and you never know when something might
come up or what his reaction might be
i i remember we're in the we're in a
meeting for game day morning and
frequently you know um it's right in the
middle of a college football game it's
on the screen
being in the fall right around you know
uh third fourth quarter of the early
games of of a college football saturday
and one time uh um one of those capital
one
commercials with the vikings shows up
and he screams out willig
and he and we're like what and he
screams
he goes that guy he was one of my
offensive linemen in san francisco
that's matt willig
and he's now an actor and look at him
that's what he screams
no that's what i'm talking about you
know i listen all the the whole career
that he had and the guys that
played for him and for him to sort of
pick that and recognize me
that just kind of says it all it really
does oh he knew he knew the whole thing
and he's like yeah he's trying to be an
actor
and blah blah blah and and by the way
now look at you
on an nbc show you all know you're still
trying you're you're achieving sir
you're achieving um
matthew willock here uh on the rich
eisen show what in the world is it like
to play andre the giant
right now in young unique it's unique
um and and humbling and all the things
you can imagine you know i mean this guy
is true was truly an icon
um and and really the most recognized
person in the world at one point
um and still today you know even if you
don't know the
the wrestling aspect of andre the giant
you can find a woman in her 30s or 40s
who knows
fesic you know and and knows his
character
from princess bride so of course there
was there was some pressure to it you
know um i did more research for andre
and more prep for him than any other
character that i had ever done
and so um you know there's
it's been nice that uh at least right
now the critics have
given me some a little bit of props yes
so far and there's some some some good
stuff coming
excellent well uh how close in dimension
are you uh i you're like sick in real
life
you're six eight and um you know google
does have you over three bills
um but then again that's uh that's a
wikipedia situation that can be true or
false but
yeah so i lost i lost a good amount of
weight when i i got done playing
you know but even then i at six eight i
i was holding around 290
uh which is pretty good for me okay um i
chose to
uh gain about 35 pounds for this role
and um being a man in my 50s
getting 35 pounds is only fun for a
short period of time
all right it sounds like that sounds
like the mooch diet to me to be honest
with you
there was a lot of puffs involved so i'm
sure it had something to do with it but
um yeah gaining the weight was was was
part of it so i ended up getting
about 335 pounds which um
gave me sort of that that feel of andre
and that sort of uh i had a little more
of the gut
and you know later on the season when
you kind of see me in the wrestling
uh ring you'll see where where that
weight
was distributed and how it plays how
cool is that that you're playing andre
the giant getting in a wrestling ring
for a show that the rock is
cooking if you will i mean that's going
to be amazing
yeah just to go through the wrestling uh
sort of
uh rigor you know and and practicing for
it and
and uh having we had this guy named
chavo guerrero who is a famous wrestler
himself
he was uh working with us and and just
getting in the ring and doing that stuff
there was a special feel
then to put on the shorts and and and
the boots and all these things that kind
of
and you know you look to your left and
you see a guy at macho man and you look
over here and you get the smoke
the the squad samoans you know in
in iron sheik and all these guys that
you're looking at going holy
man i am i'm gonna go i'm in a good spot
right now
and then to have other guys come up to
me and go uh you know
wrestler older wrestler guys who had
known or been around andre a little bit
and said
dude it's pretty amazing how you look
wow
and are sounding like andre so again big
compliments
and um you know it's a treat to be able
to kind of bring uh
dwayne's story to life a little bit well
i mean and uh matthew williger on the on
the rich eisen show
um uh for those who may not have seen
young
rock yet it goes over you mentioned
dwayne johnson who goes over his life
and his life stories
as he looks back when he's running for
president in 2032 which means
this is all true um so um
is it also true that you met the rock
dwayne johnson
at an equinox 10 years ago and went up
to him and that's your first interaction
with him
is that a true story that's uh that's
true only because i
started that rumor um
[Applause]
when you start a lie yes becomes the
truth rich okay
um no i did uh up in the valley above la
and we were i was working out
and dwayne was there he used to own a
home nearby and
um you know even back then he hadn't
made it huge yet but he was still the
rock i mean
and he would come in and keep himself
but uh
i was able to sort of we worked in you
know did sets together and
did a few machines together and kind of
had a little internet introduction to
each other
and i had just had a uh my sort of big
movie first big film
uh the year one with jack black coming
out and
uh you know i pulled him aside and
picked his brain a little bit and said
hey i'm just
i'm trying to kind of you know raise my
status as an
actor in the business what do you think
about this and i just kind of threw a
couple questions out to him and uh
he was very sweet to me you know and
didn't give me the brush off and
answered a couple questions and
uh you know it's i spent the last decade
trying to get to work with him since
then and
had run into him a couple times where he
you know he was cool enough to stop and
say hi to me and you know there was a
recognition there which was nice
and even when i got this job uh one of
the things he did
say to me was you know it's great that
we finally get to work together you know
so there was that sort of whole
circle uh thing and and uh and so yeah
that's how it started okay so what's
more courageous what takes more courage
matthew
pass protecting against reggie white or
asking to work in with the rock
as he's working out at a gym what takes
more courage
well the less brains you have the both
of them kind of equal the same
if you just go in and you don't think
about it then that's
sort of that's my mo man it's you know
it's funny you mentioned reggie white
uh i i was very fortunate to play
well against reggie white to the point
where when i ended up playing with him
um in in green bay and then actually
later on in caroline i met him
from carolina he he actually came up to
me at one point and said you were one of
the toughest guys ever went against hey
you handled
you know my uh my signature move
uh my little forklift move that i had
better than anybody else and i was like
i took a moment i almost i think i
should have curious at that point
because you know reggie white just said
that i was one of the toughest guys
so uh what another another crazy little
dot
a little blip on my uh on my career uh
of cool things that have happened
dude if you got that you can do
anything andre the giant is just the
freaking beginning
period and the story honestly down from
here
no it's only you've got you can do
anything i mean my gosh
matt it was pretty incredible it's uh um
it was pretty sweet of him and and again
another soul lost you know
i know that i know that another first
ballot hall of famer
uh inducted posthumously as well my gosh
uh hey
look congrats on your career and how it
is going and let's do this more often
let's do this morning thank you rich i
always appreciate talking to you um you
got a great sense of humor and that's
what i love i can bring it on your show
and uh
i'll have to do more things so i can get
back on absolutely and next time we'll
we'll bring up kevin barlow's cell phone
once again okay
you take care matthew thank you brother
okay there you go
that's called a parting shot if you will
and laying uh the groundwork
right in there
at matthew willig on twitter at
mojowillig on instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here